I need one ammo box in one chest to get
us that was into XP Wow which i think is
like a whole level pretty much Wow
in the bottom left my tap my event
challenges my daily challenges I don't
have anything there does that mean I
already did them for the day or maybe it
means you sucked all the same here dude
yeah we're on the same team if you got
served
whoa whoa Bob go easy on them go easy on
them come on man call the fire
department
it's that was sick burn savage that
Bruno Mars song ah you better call the
I'm like a dragon
somebody call nine one yeah alright what
are you doing somebody call 9-1-1 cuz
this is clean wait that's a different
song so we good tomato town it's kind of
there i liked i mean i think it was
lucky that we won the big fight but i
like the big fight
yeah tomato town alright let's go to
minute then I'm done telling them push
anarchy acres okay because there's not a
whole lot of like stuff in tomato town
so either we're gonna die or we're gonna
get a get a little bit of loot and then
we should juicy fo yeah I agree
is there anything in the woods yeah
there's like a middle area I've never
been there and stuff lots of yeah lots
of wood you could get I guess there's
lots of Bonners I'm gonna hit the house
I don't get it we have we have fresh new
[ __ ] or enemies here I'm gonna guess
enemies are they going to like the
little gas station bit I'm gonna land at
I don't like this [ __ ] [ __ ] there's a
guy in here with a goddess this guy is
not an ally I'm gonna try to [ __ ] him
but I cannot guarantee any sort of [ __ ]
äj-- Oh for god sakes
I don't even have anything
I've got an enemy here with me I'm dead
oh I couldn't hit this guy for [ __ ] okay
well three shots where are you at mark I
can't [ __ ] there he is it [ __ ]
spectate markiplier to your left in that
Oh behind you there's a person in there
that killed me in that building I'm
gonna go to wait cuz I'm scared there's
a person here too we're alone that guy
I'm not gonna let him get the rebug but
ah [ __ ] never mind bye [ __ ]
wait up I blame you bye yeah well
apparently you have like one health so
oh boy kill him wait when you got this
die what wow wow she gotta hit those wow
wow we all shotgun was not the combat
shot we we all saw that we all saw
[Laughter]
replay that right now enhancing zoom in
on where he's breaking like his spirit
breaks right here wow wow she gotta get
those and there wow wow yeah there it is
okay yeah that's sad that's got
Wonderwall is the song here's it to a
Smash Mouth wait wait no sing a
rendition we'll put it over that that's
it I got I was drinking the my drink
while I sing that wait Sarah McLaughlin
and the dummy are Sarah McLaughlin
holding the dummy
I guess you you're not wrong so pleasant
park where everyone's gonna go oh hell
yeah let's [ __ ] do it let's jam bag
in this bad boy oh I'm gonna try a blue
jump as soon as you can my friends oh
you know I will you know I will no one
else is coming here get the [ __ ] down on
the ground and kill follow mall there's
so many people I'm gonna go to this
little [ __ ] no I'm gonna go to this
house there's no one's at this house
that I met [ __ ] there's a guy here at
this house I met [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] please
land that's a bad guy with a shotgun oh
god these are all bad guys by me oh
where I'm coming
we got whoa that is a bad guy I'm hiding
in a smoke how the [ __ ] did I go down
what no no I couldn't hit this dude oh
[ __ ] they just killed me wait apparently
he freaked out through a smoke and left
he's like [ __ ] sake I had this guy too
but I didn't see a grenade being tossed
Wade you got it apparently he literally
cannot hit [ __ ] I've never I can't
imagine we met somebody there's a chest
in the doghouse behind you there's a
chest in that doghouse break the
doghouse chest
don't break the chest get the gun get
your bed pack shoot him oh my god this
guy's a [ __ ] ninja no he's not kill
him wait okay okay there's other people
wait you might want to look away or yeah
wait definitely die eventually okay it's
too late it's too late for Wade all that
person's get shot at oh they just go
down no in this town oh nevermind
they're right there get him Wade nice
nice all right that's not it good job
good job good job good job well then you
really almost stole that kill another
guy to the left
shoot him wait do guys you might want to
run wait no Wade's a no fight oh that's
an enemy as well what's an enemy just
killed an enemy no no no that's not it
okay I don't I'm not seeing friendly
indicators on my screen yeah that guy's
so savage right now yeah I can't eat Wow
his merciless you failed my team that's
this is one too many times wait get the
blue combat shotgun for [ __ ] sake I
don't they're trying to wade Wow it's
the gun in this game that is so Opie
it's broke let let us criticize you
right now way because obviously you're
not doing as good as you should hey hey
it's in the Attic I think wood yeah okay
spammy spammy
get all the things get the juice Wade
you better go on to win this yeah that
one oh oh I keep thinking it's enemies
but its allies yeah
'we don't suck a backed it on this one
what was what be not and I totally won
that round you gotta live up to that
yeah exactly
I remember that I recorded that to my
mind without us being alive yeah I won
that one yeah you won that one I was
there I saw it
hmm you really want to focus on like
walls and trees Wade yeah
hey who's alive who doesn't know what
they're doing that's right both answers
are me mmm there you go that's the good
stuff
mmm you have any heels there bud I guess
you're at 73 yeah yeah I think I can
only get to 75 can't I have you haven't
have you had some like a meal are you
low on sugar your blood Sugar's low a
little I've got some crackers here okay
that's good all right just remember to
keep eating you need to keep your energy
up you're gonna be running a lot out
there just yeah I might even mute myself
for you guys because every time I see
another character right now my mind you
can't see the arrow all three of those
guys are enemies Oh Jase you're
surrounded I can't stop oh hey we're
winning right now numbers voice just
yeah and four houses here to take down
houses in real life yeah I only needs a
mallet hammered pickaxe and will to live
I mean two perfectly honest if you had a
pickaxe and you go for the structural
supports I'd imagine a house would go
down I'm pretty sure why is that
happening oh that's a smoke okay the
smokes are very like very smoke yeah
they are bushy they're very bush they're
very bushy ask is this person just
paranoid or actually something up here I
mean well he threw him up there yeah he
threw him up oh he threw them yeah oh
well that changes it yeah he or she
knows somebody threw smokes up there
guys let's get out Gary we saw you throw
the smokes
Gary
with someone else we gotta go
investigate listen Randall did he gotta
believe me I wouldn't go view like this
Randall
really I came up with a great name like
Gary no yeah no I was being Gary and I
was talking to Randall Oh oldest what
that uh no I just walked off I was like
oh yeah I thought he was just going for
I don't want to live in this world
anymore
eerie [ __ ] Gary what about Randall
he's alright I don't acknowledge Randall
no I'm telling you who was Gary talking
to then who's talking to Gary one not
named Randall I think it was Randall I'm
not complaining about the character of
Randall I'm just saying I put a lot of
thought into my name and then you just
vomited out Randall beautiful Toby's
Toby's here just know Toby get the [ __ ]
out of here and don't discussion area
you need to shut up he's not here please
leave Toby Toby Toby your name is Jeremy
and get the [ __ ] out on one port awesome
come on Toby listen wait focus on being
bad at this game and leave the comedian
leave the comedy to the professionals
here all right so Randall
just because my brain works faster than
yours and can come up with names faster
and great names like Randall just spew
forth out of my brain doesn't mean you
can [ __ ] on it Bob comedy uh excuse you
it's because you can come up with
Randall in half a second does it mean
that suddenly that means Randall's a
viable name oh and I'm just supposed to
wait five minutes for you to contemplate
the essence of Gary what does the
audience gonna do nothing cuz they're
bored out of their mind the detailed and
specific scene that we have set with our
physical actions implying exactly where
we are and what we're doing oh okay all
right and then we're just gonna do that
without names for the first few minutes
is that what
big boys would do it let that [ __ ]
simmer before you put name is wins no
you cannot walk in the water very slowly
mmm anyway totally just totally shut the
[ __ ] up Toby Toby shut up please bring
that back is an actual improv character
stow me it won't be season gonna bode
Wow
Toby good job says get this good Toby
says Toby says [ __ ] it
Wow Toby you are very rude Toby Toby
that was completely uncalled for I have
to say Toby Toby yeah okay you're not in
a circle by the way I know this is real
fun and all but like Toby maybe you
should like get to safety
he's on his way all right Dobby someone
bill Toby a dog for all his bones how
many boats do you have Toby Toby [ __ ]
I like the lack of confidence in that
delivery
hey Toby what do you want to have for
lunch okay are you gonna wash down that
delicious burger with Toby at Oh
beverage is that Toby beverage and [ __ ]
all in one word sugar look at these
riches be Toby I didn't know that Toby
was such a great great improviser here
Toby he's killing it craftsman I can't
even believe that Toby listen Toby I I'm
almost hesitant to ask but what's uh
what's your what's your mother's name
Toby
and and you and your father
toby senior you you know when you're
answered the river back there you got
your boots really wet you kind of got
your whole outfit wet we found like the
perfect comedic character for wade
because it combines puns his strong suit
[Laughter]
Toby I heard you got a dog recently what
did you what do you name the little
scamp little Toby and your son I
hesitate to ask again but your son if
your dog's little Toby what do you
what's your son's name
[Laughter]
okay
all right waiter you gonna actually kill
someone here do we have to come up with
more amazing humor first and what's
happening it's gotta be someone here you
can kill they're trying to kill you holy
[ __ ]
maybe maybe they have that guy okay Jody
yeah I'm sorry
Toby I think your reign of toeb is over
yeah you guys want to watch the end of
this Wow okay good job okay okay that's
a good most snap they [ __ ] built their
own sniper oh they're in trouble with
shefte you could do this
jump a lot everyone who wins this game
jumps a lot you did enough jumping well
they might win this one bad Michelle
it's just not up near the enemy they're
all down south just like sucking their
own toe gimme a 16-7 like it should be a
clear winner here weirder things have
happened though Bhaskar is about to go
do some work I can whoa
peasant two of our teammates quickly go
down kim jeong-hoon e is tearing it up
yeah
I can't believe my chest is still alive
how's my chest is still alive Kim Jang
hoon II is dead mom again your teammate
ears though I shouldn't have rushed in
like an idiot but I just want to have
some of the action yeah whatever
chilling out let's just is gonna get
back up
I can't believe this reminds nice one in
the dirt in the distance oh you're just
finishing them off it's only two two
left guys
well Majesta wow what it was here one
left guys that guys down hmm
where's my chest is majestic gonna
redeem majesta Majesta is bandaging up
for no apparent reason
oh we have all right we have 14 yeah
come on guys like the the freaking
grenade launcher whoa wow that was a
good shot on agar ya mus an ogre - yeah
burger burger burger
[Music]